hi guys scifi recapped here
before we start warning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain a
2018 south korean historical epic action
movie called the great battle which
follows the story of the antsy fortress
siege by the tang dynasty in 645 a.d
the movie begins with emperor tai zhang
the emperor of china invading the
kukuryo kingdom in korea
he is called the god of war due to his
ambitious determination to conquer the
whole land
general yen of kokuryo dispatches 150
000 men to face taizong's army at mount
jupiter while emperor tai zhong watches
the battle from afar and is confident of
his army strength yen's men are
determined to hold their ground despite
being far outnumbered turns out another
hidden chinese army attacks young's men
from behind the lines forcing them to
retreat one of the men samuel grieves
over the death of his brother and
decides to carry his dead body on his
back until general yun tells him to
leave his brother out of the 150 000 men
only less than 10 000 survived
meanwhile emperor tai zhong and his
generals discuss plans for their next
move
a captured korean woman a holy medium
who can foresee the future forbids the
chinese people to touch kokurya's
ancient bow which belonged to holy king
chamong believing it to be a sacred
relic the men continued to discuss their
next plan explaining to the emperor that
they have to conquer the antsy fortress
next before taking over the capital of
kokuryo they think they can take the
fortress without bloodshed because of
the feud between nancy commander mon
chun yang and general yun
moreover the holy medium was engaged
with yang putting the chinese at an
advantage on the other hand general yun
already suspects emperor tai zhong is
going to strike antsy fortress next
he tells somal that commander yang did
not send reinforcements to help his army
at the previous battles hence he calls
him a traitor therefore he wants samuel
to kill commander yang as he believes
samuel can carry out the mission due to
his loyalty even though he came from
ansi
general yun tells samal to rejoin the
army in the capital after completing his
mission
on his way to ansi samuel meets two
korean soldiers who go along with him
they help a group of commoners whose
carriage is stuck in the muddy path then
ask one of them to bring them to meet
commander yang of ansi to their surprise
the person they are helping is commander
yang himself who stays composed despite
being suspicious of them
yang's men check the soldiers horses and
deduce that they are taizon spies then
kill them swiftly
samul however manages to explain that he
came from ansi the last of the yuubal
clan
he claims to flee from the chinese army
and decides to stand with the antsy
people yang decides not to kill him but
ties him up and will interrogate him
later inside the fortress they then move
to ansi a lively town hidden behind the
fortress
a brawl occurs in the market between
huabo and pong two of yang's trusted men
yang resolves the fight by telling the
men to mind their own business
jualbo who is proficient with axes must
continue his work to repair the fortress
wall with his men
back at his house yang tells samol that
he knows young labeled him a traitor and
questions samal's motives to serve him
in ansi he then introduces samuel to his
second in command chu as well as huabo
and pong
he then assigns samuel to be his flag
bearer being close to him at all times
to notify his position during the battle
later that night samuel stalks him
visiting the house of a newborn baby who
is named after himself
samuel realizes how loved commander yang
is by the antsy people the next day
samuel asks chu what kind of leader
general yang is to which he replies that
the people like to think of the general
as the antsy fortress itself
ansi will not be the same without him he
says
general yang looks for paso the leader
of the cavalry who turns out to be
hanging out with his sister becca
yang wants to kill paso for dating bec
ha but she stands up for him they are
interrupted by the news of arriving
chinese scouts
they deduce that tai zhong and his army
are not far behind and will shortly
attack the fortress in preparing for the
battle general yang asks samuel to see
his dagger and trim his beard
samul knows it is the perfect moment to
kill yang but he could not bring himself
to do it
seeing his shaking hands yang knows
samal was sent by yun to kill him but he
tells him that there will be another
opportunity to kill him if samuel wishes
to do it
they then head to battle
the main army arrives an impressive size
against five thousand antsy men
general yang gives words of
encouragement to his army telling them
to fight for ansi and cherish their life
here to breach the fortress wall the
chinese army throws rocks using
trebuchets however they fail to breach
the wall due to the strong structural
integrity of the fortress the antsy
archers are skillful they are able to
hold the chinese army from approaching
the fortress
although the main wooden gate is
breached the antsy army has prepared a
circling wooden fence to trap chinese
soldiers breaching the gate
they then form a close order formation
to push the soldiers from the fortress
emperor tai zhong orders retreat back at
his home commander yang shows samal his
scars from battling the tang army and
young spies telling samuel it is no use
to kill him because then yun will just
send another spy the antsy people are
gathering outside having a feast to
celebrate today's victory
samuel points his dagger at yang asking
why he did not obey general yun
he tells him his duty is to protect the
fortress not obey general yun he did not
send his men to help reinforce general
yun's army because that would leave the
fortress defenseless
later that evening tai zhong's army is
back to assault the fortress now with
siege towers and firebows
yang instructs his men to ready the oil
pouches and burns the siege towers by
hitting them himself
he is hit by a spear and is almost
killed but somal defends him
after four days he wakes up relieving
the whole town
chu and the others who have doubted
samal's loyalty now respect him as he
saved yang
although the town rejoices from
surviving another assault emperor tai
zhong made the holy medium for seance's
future
based on that prophecy the chinese army
builds a mound of dirt higher than the
fortress so they can attack it from the
same level
the holy medium is then sent to antsy to
deliver the ancient bow and bring the
message to surrender
receiving the message samol suggests
asking for reinforcements from the
capital but the men doubt reinforcements
will come
aso suggests they strike emperor tai
zhong directly while the mound is still
constructed as the army is not too
concerned about security although becca
strongly disagrees with the notion no
one can deny that it is the only way
they can try
paso and his men ride to emperor
taizhong's encampment but the ambush is
detected so they are trapped
paso manages to come back to the
commander before his last breath
they learn that the holy medium has
alerted emperor tai zhong about the
ambush she explains that there will be
no way for antsy to win except by
surrendering to emperor tai zhang as she
has seen the doom future
samuel slits her throat refusing to
believe that ansi will fall
consumed by grief becca aims to kill
emperor tai zhang by herself but is also
defeated her body is returned to the
fortress so general yang can properly
bury beckha and paso together
he decides to float their bodies down
the river samul decides to go to general
yun
he begs for general yun to help antsy
people because although yang can be seen
as a traitor he and antsy people are
still kokurya people and they fight
valiantly for the country meanwhile yang
gets an idea to topple the mound
constructed by the chinese army after
seeing little children playing with dirt
and rock he discusses his idea with
local miners led by wu day who agree
that the local soil consists of loose
pebbles that can be easily topped if
they dig a cave system beneath the mound
however as the steep side of the mound
is pointing toward the fortress they
must time the toppling perfectly to
prevent the chinese soldiers from
advancing towards the fortress by the
time they topple it after a few days the
cave work is almost done
they planned to burn the columns of the
mound structure in the morning
however rainfall during the night caused
the cave to be filled with water and
made the columns too wet to be burned
wuday agrees to chop down the columns
using axes sacrificing him and his men
to be buried beneath the mound they chop
the columns and the mound fails just as
the chinese soldiers are advancing
toward the fortress
yang and his men take over the mound
quickly and drive off the remaining
chinese army still on the mound and
raging emperor tai zhong he will not
stop the assault until yang is dead so
the battle goes on for days day and
night until yang and his men run out of
arrows and other ammunition
he asks one of his men to retrieve the
chumang ancient bow and intends to aim
it at emperor tai zhong while praying
that the gods of kukuryu help him the
tai zhong army is advancing on them but
yang's men are determined to guard their
commander and hold their ground no
matter what the arrow leaves yang's
hands and accurately hits one of emperor
taizong's eyes badly injuring him
the long-awaited reinforcements of
general yun and his army arrive trapping
the chinese army on both sides
they flee and admit defeat while
commander yang rejoices with the antsy
people he notices samuel from general
yun's army approaching him above the
fortress and embraces him three years
after returning home emperor tai zhong
succumbs to his wounds and dies
meanwhile the antsy fortress is being
rebuilt and peace is restored in kukuryo
samul prepares to head back to the
capital city to finish his military
academy bidding farewell to commander
yang who tells him to return to ansi
anytime he wishes
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching